orégano é uma erva riquíssima em
antioxidantes com propriedades
antiinflamatórias antibacterianas e
antifúngicas seus compostos ativos podem
ajudar aliviar sintomas de resfriados
gripes e alergias respiratórias os usos
terapêuticos que eu considero mais
impressionantes do orégano são no
combate aos fungos e na diminuição da
inflamação ele é um potente agente
antifúngico pessoal muito utilizado para
combater e tratar a proliferação de
fungos no intestino Ou seja a famosa
síndrome fúngica o óleo essencial já é
bastante conhecido no tratamento da
micose de unha e geralmente é utilizado
em conjunto com outras substâncias
antifúngicas ele também possui uma
substância chamada betacar fileno que
funciona como canabinoide reduzindo a
inflamação e auxiliando no tratamento da
osteoporose e da síndrome metabólica